okay once more if I can have your
attention please can everybody hear me
in the back back there
also if you're if you're in the back end
if anybody is standing we also have the
monitors on tonight there's a monitor in
the cafe and there's also a monitor by
one of the registers next to you so if
anybody wants to get a slightly better
view you can go to the cafe or you can
go to that monitor out there again
welcome to book passage I'm Dana Kelly
pleasure to have you all here always a
pleasure to have Mary Roach back
pregnant she's been here for any number
of her of her titles and it's always a
pleasure to have her back at book
passage tonight is grunt tonight is
about what the military has to go
through we're not going to Mars tonight
we're going to the frontlines and there
are some things that I certainly didn't
know that you will find out tonight
about what the military has to go
through in various ways and I will just
mention one which I don't know if Mary
will talk about tonight part of the
things we learn in this book is how
diarrhea could be a threat to national
security
agreed
quick blurb from the from the Boston
Globe Mary Roach is latest bit of
brilliance as meticulously researched
beautifully written in disturbingly
funny as her previous books grunt
examines the science behind war as well
as the researchers who are leading the
charge in the state-of-the-art
developments Roach's prose is a triumph
and engaging blend of anecdote research
and reflection Mary Roach as many of you
know is also the author of packing for
Mars the curious science of life and the
void
bonk the curious coupling of science and
sex spook science tackles the afterlife
and stiff the curious lives of human
cadavers and her writing has appeared in
about every magazine you can possibly
imagine and she's going to be in
conversation tonight with our own Jeff
Greenwald if you're a fan of travel
writing just as the author of five
best-selling books including shopping
for Buddhas scratching the surface
future perfect house star trek conquered
planet Earth and his latest is snake
Lake and Jeff is also on our factory of
factories
yeah Jeff works in our Factory and
besides that he's also on the Faculty of
our Travel Writers Conference so if
there are any budding writers in the in
the audience tonight you can find out
more about our conferences there's a
mystery one in July and one in August
and Jeff will be on the faculty of that
and you can find out all the information
about those before you leave tonight or
in our newsletter so without further ado
would you please welcome Mary Roach and
Jeff Greenwald hi she wants anything
about your voice or with your voice
speak for itself I have a yeah well I'm
a little a few octave lower and more
sultry owing to a case of lyric well
it's not really laryngitis anymore
because it's you can hear me now
yesterday would have been the yeah so
anyway anyway I'm hoping it holds out
we've got te here and to be good so
let's go right into it thanks everybody
for coming Thank You Dana for the great
introduction I'm going to start with
that with this question Mary um your
work always sprouts from very unusual
seeds so what gave birth to grunt
actually was close to it was a seed it
was a chili pepper it was I was
reporting a piece on the world's hottest
chili pepper I was in India and someone
told me well I was reporting on this
chili pepper and this contest for people
eat this unbelievably hot chili pepper
someone said you know the Indian
military weaponized this chili pepper
and I thought well I really need to
report on that so I went over to this
lab of the science lab that the Indian
Army maintains and to talk to them about
the chili pepper which they've never
deployed because the man said it was
prone to mildew so um so it kind of
bombed so the chili the Chili's
exploding chili pepper grenade never
never was
never was deployed but while I was there
there were other interesting things
going on they were working on a leech
repellent while I was there that I found
what was that was just right up my alley
I don't know a leech repel so that was
kind of where the idea came from I
thought military science sounds far more
esoteric and maybe more rocha belen you
might think so that and that's what got
the ball rolling
yeah the Rocha Bowl thing is something
I'd like to ask you about
so Rocha ball so all of your books are
really they're wonderful they're
scientifically enlightening and they're
really funny and and kind of breezy a
lot of them did you feel any any sort of
worry about bringing this kind of
lightness or breeziness or humor to the
world of soldiers which are kind of
sacred in the United States right now
soldiers are our heroes they sacrifice a
lot how did you feel about bringing your
humor to that subject a lot of a lot of
trepidation about that a lot of concern
that I wanted to I have to I have to be
me I got to be me it's got to be a Mary
Roach book so they had to be funny it
had to be had some levity on the other
hand like you said this is war and
people are injured in many ways and I
didn't want to be disrespectful or make
light of things in an inappropriate way
so I tended to make fun of myself as the
clueless outsider that I truly was for
example I would at one point I have a
chapter on basically how do you do how
to design a vehicle for basically
automotive safety for people who drive
on bombs you know how do you create a
vehicle that will keep the passengers
safe to if something a bomb comes up for
underneath so they were showing me
around this large armored vehicle and
they were talking about how it had to be
stripped down because you couldn't just
keep adding more armor because I would
make it so heavy it'd be too heavy for
the engine for the brakes etc so it was
very stripped down inside and I said oh
it's great that you still have
cupholders and Vic I said Mary those are
rifle holders
so and that kind of made what happened
over and over because I really am NOT I
haven't spent any time in the mill J I
don't have family my father my father's
very was very old he was 65 when I was
born he actually enlisted in World War
one he was born in England they lived
here and made it as far as basic
training where he got a hernia and that
was that for the illustrious Roche
military career so you is this feeding I
think it is so in terms of your being
kind of this person who blunders into
these situations without knowing much
about them you covered so many subjects
now the last one that was sort of a
little bit similar perhaps to grunt was
packing for Mars where you you work
inside of NASA in the space program was
it harder to get access to the military
or to the space program you would think
the military but in fact it wasn't as
difficult as NASA the military was very
they were very straightforward it was
either to is this project classified if
so then no did just right up front no
but if it wasn't classified people were
very helpful and willing to kind of you
know help me get a problem that the
difficulty was when the people were
saying no it was nobody felt they had
authority to say yes so you never like
15 people you know I can't say yes but I
think you have to ask these people and
those people would sort of ping-ponging
back and forth and it took a year and a
half to get on a Trident submarine year
and a half and not again it was just
trying to find the just a way on there
in that case partly because I wanted to
be only on for a few days not the months
that they're out there I do like to
immerse myself in reporting but it has
its limits the good news is you can get
on the bad news is you'll be on for 12
months that exactly yeah so the beauty
in all of your books is really in the
details and their details that are sort
of unforgettable one of them for me was
um in your chapter about military
uniforms you mentioned that the United
States government buttons specifications
guide the button specifications guide is
20
two pages long and I was amazed to read
that the army requires that its clothing
designers have a fashion design degree
isn't that sort of an oxymoron
well yeah you would that you would think
so I was surprised as well and the woman
that I was talking to in the design lab
at Natick labs Natick labs is where they
design basically the accessories of
being a soldier the clothing the things
you carry the things you sleep in the
tents sleeping bags whatever they have a
design lab for the uniforms and this
woman had a fashion degree and she her
background was in swimwear design I
thought that makes no kind of sense to
me and she said well actually if you
think about it it does because a bathing
suit is for specialized activity
athletic activity it's in a specialized
environment it's water so it has to be
you know it has to it has to give it has
to react with the water in a certain way
so in fact she felt that her background
in swimsuit design wasn't was in fact a
fairly appropriate one and the other
woman there had worked for Priscilla's
of Boston high-end wedding gowns she
said here again okay what's a wedding
gown
it's layering of specialty fabrics very
similar to like body armor or like or
like it but you might certain marriages
need one thing we learned from your book
is that is that something that you think
would be a lot of great danger to
soldiers like sharks a if they if they
go overboard are actually no problem at
all but some things you really don't
think about like diarrhea which as much
are a gigantic problem why is diarrhea
such a grave problem for soldiers well
let me tell you well first of all his
there's historically diarrhea was
there's a dr. William Osler had a great
quote he's a famous I don't know father
of modern medicine I don't know that
much about him it's just what they call
anyway he was the one who said dysentery
has been more fatal to soldiers than
powder or shot in the stitches because
we bear that out the mexican-american
war is the example it's kind of
amazing seven soldiers died from
dysentery and disease mostly dysentery
versus one killed in combat so and what
would happen you would have these field
camps and you've got the mess tent where
you're preparing food no no
refrigeration and you've got an open
like pit latrine and flies unbelievable
number of flies also attracted by if any
bodies were around so the Flies are
landing you know on the latrine material
and then buzzing over to the beans which
are sitting there so the Flies are a
mechanical vector which means they land
on the crap and then they have these
pathogens on their feet and they
inoculate the food which sits there for
two hours and then the whole camp gets
dysentery or yellow fever or whatever it
is
typhoid fever whatever the pathogen is
so it was a tremendous problem now it's
not because there's good hygiene on
bases there's that the basis we have air
conditioning so the whole dining
facility could be sealed so you'll never
have to open a windows there's no flies
anymore so that's not a problem but it
is a problem if you're saying special
operations you're one of those guys
who's going out on a small unit in say a
small village in Somalia Yemen you're
doing counterinsurgency work and those
people are eating what the locals eat
and the water is not often not safe in
the food and they the rates of diarrhea
with those folks are very high twice the
rate of ordinary enlisted soldiers and
you could imagine if you were going to I
don't know take down Osama bin Laden
whatever your assignment was and you are
hit with extreme gastrointestinal
urgency that's a problem for national
security do they have any miracle drugs
that we don't know about
well they were testing well I went all
the way I went all the way to Djibouti
Africa for the diarrhea chapter that's
just the kind of gal I am so in a lot of
Special Operations Navy sylvans that are
going out to various Yemen Somalia is
very North Africa and then I went with a
diarrhea researcher who is testing a a
very quick one dose regimen where you
would at least be now
back on your feet in a few in a matter
of hours rather than days so that's
that's one thing that's what they were
testing so that's the main secret top so
you know actually it'll be coming soon
to a drugstore near you one thing that
was interesting in the book is that you
know we always sort of take for granted
that that Mexico is kind of like the
poster child for travelers you know
turista but but how Mexico won that
honor he's kind of interesting little
story yeah if you go on to PubMed which
is a database of all of the medical
journals most of them anyway and you put
in diarrhea and Guadalajara you will get
thirty five journal articles so I feel
so sorry for Guadalajara it is like a
synonymous with diarrhea because Herbert
DuPont the godfather of diarrhea
research honestly this man has done more
but for counteracting diarrhea than any
man on the planet he I don't know if
he's retired now but anyway Herbert
DuPont setup he thought were people
getting sick he went he set up a lab in
Guadalajara at the University using
students and tourists as his study
subjects and published a lot of papers
Guate la do you think the reason he's
never won a Nobel Prize in medicine is
just because the Nobel Committee is
embarrassed to call him up I would think
he's probably won an ignoble so you
dressed up you dressed up at one point
for this role as a as a newbie
journalist in some of these situations
you were with a group called strategic
operations was that the name of it where
you had can play a role in a theatrical
recreation of a war scene what was that
like what was the role that you that you
played well strategic operations is it's
a big movie studio in Southern
California that is now used for training
combat medics and Navy corpsman who do
the medicine for the Marine Corps and it
that it's because of the films that were
made there used to be action films war
films so they're really good at violence
gore loud noises and explosions so it's
perfect for setting up these simulations
so
and they have actors come in it and it's
hyper-realistic is the word that they
use they've trademark the word
like realistic and so these medics and
Carmen these guys they were in training
and guys and I think some of them are
when they're coming in and they're
immersed in this scenario that is it's
very intense we've got pyrotechnics
they're duds but they sound real and
they have dust hits so it looks like
rifle fires actually happening there are
actors some of them are amputees who
have a latex sleeve on the stump with
you know really really impressive gore
and a backpack with stage blood that is
pumped at accurate rate and there's a
remote control for the bleeding and if
the Navy corpsman is putting the
tourniquet on properly the bleeding will
slow and if it's not put on properly the
continues to bleed and then they the
actor you know gets very quiet and
meanwhile the instructors are screaming
and it's a very intense scenario so I in
order to get close enough so I could see
what was going on I requested a roll
they were like we don't know what to do
with you and I suggested that I just
play a journalist who gets in the way as
type post typecast so that that's what I
did
how did these doctors do in that in that
situation like do they keep their calm
was the reason to feel confident about
their abilities in the field there was a
big difference between the first is a
two day course the first round of
experiment simulations versus the last
was a tremendous difference the first
one was you know there would be a guy
who would go to pick up a stretcher and
you have to coordinate picking up a
stretcher if the other guy in the other
end it doesn't know the patient falls
off so this one guy Baker kept he did
that twice another time he stood the
wrong way so he's backing up and
meanwhile of you know the you know
instructors like Baker
you know just yelling it using a lot of
words I can't use on c-span - was it fun
were you actually kind of terrified Jude
in the spirit of the
through that well it you definitely or
your adrenaline gets going and just
probably from the loud noises and the
startle response from from the guns the
gun and fire even though it's not real
and that's part of what's important
because the fight-or-flight response you
get this boost of adrenaline you know
that the fight-or-flight response is
great if you need to fight or run away
but if you need to cut an emergency
airway or apply a tourniquet or do a
needle decompression somebody's lung is
collapsed you that that's not helpful
for you so they need to be practicing
these skills in like the worst physical
scenario when you're like flooded with
adrenaline and and that and that makes
you shaking - you're also their hands
would be shaking so that's kind of what
the so it wasn't so much I wasn't you
know afraid for my life but you
definitely aren't real it's not a
relaxing afternoon yeah you became sort
of a method actor that yeah I one thing
I love about your books is that you get
to be really scientist so you'd
otherwise never hear of people who are
sort of on the front line to some really
obscure form of research what are the
qualities that attract you in a
scientist when you when you do these
books you know I don't know who they're
going to be till I go and meet them
often I've only exchanged emails which
is a testament to scientists in general
that they're they tend to be really
interesting people I had no idea what
George Peck would be like George Peck
was a worked for Walter Reid the
Department of military entomology he was
the fill fly and maggot guy and not at
all what I kind of expected a very
sensitive philosophical soul who loved
nature in all its forms including the
maggot he had such you maggots are used
I should say I should you know explain
the maggots in a wound could perform
this amazing function they eat the dead
tissue which encourages the growth of
the new tissue and they fight infection
in that way so they do debridement which
you it is typically done surgically but
in World War two these soldiers would
come in with these horrible wounds and
then take the maggots out and the wounds
were doing great they weren't infected
so George spec was looking into using
maggots at Walter Reed for some of the
ie D injuries and well uh uh George V
IUD injuries now I yeah exactly yeah the
ie D injury yeah he started put this on
me two weeks ago at a talk Jeff Jeff
said totally yeah he goes so Mary when
when you talk about soldiers who've been
hurt by I u DS I'm sorry sorry that's
alright would you think a guy anyway
yeah anyway with it when an IEE D goes
off because it's a buried explosive it
blasts all this debris and sand and dirt
deeply into the toe wound and said a lot
of problems with infection so George
Peck was looking at bringing maggots
into the armored armory of the surgeon
and then like trying to get people okay
with that but he so he said you know you
had me over to dinner and he said I'll
raise a clutch of maggots for you
especially for you wouldn't you and when
you arrive they'll be the same age as
maggots as the maggots we've introduced
into wounds so I got there and they we
had dinner and we was finishing my wine
and George spec went away and he came
back what looked to me like a cut glass
bowl with chocolate pudding but it was
actually raw liver with my clutch of
maggots in there happily feeding which
is what maggots do they love to eat and
if any one George was saying look at the
in he took he took it he said put a
couple of them on my fingertip and he
and he had me look side the context of
the raw liver you know or whatever you
know maggots it's all context when you
take them out of the rotting body or the
the liver they're they're cute they're
kind of like the size of a cup killing
brinjal they are they're very cute all
right they are and he was like this
exists that those little creatures those
mandibles can do what no surgeon's
scalpel can do we have this real just
tremendous respect and passion for these
little creatures
I love someone like George Peck I didn't
know that that's what I was getting when
I showed up there but anyway have you
heard from George Peck since the books
come out uh just to thank me for the
book I didn't I don't know if he's read
it yet or I didn't get any feedback he
and his maggots are some of the most you
know memorable characters in the book in
however many maggots however many who
came in contact with among the strangest
programs you report on in in grunt is
the Army's attempt to create a truly
noxious stink bomb but it wasn't really
a bomb yeah well actually is it you mean
the world war two one of the more recent
ones the more recent one a more recent
one
it's a mallow Durant it's a non-lethal
weapon that is a horrible smell used to
clear a room like if I had one here in
my bag
that's actually not now it's not I did I
did have I did have a mallow drink
called stench soup which was the most
effective it cross-culturally in any
context this was the stink that everyone
loved and feared and I had a sample and
Mike shilling my idea we're I not here
tonight I had an idea that perhaps the
place I should open my simple
essentially was a republican national
gets it yeah yeah let us let us
metaphorically right now open this open
the stench soup and hold our noses I
think you'd be redundant it was like
yeah
so what stench loop is interesting
because the how it's made was made the
Monell chemical senses Center has a
woman named Pam Dalton and she works
with bad smells and I thought you know
it seems pretty easy you just sort of
get us in something that smells like
olih trene or whatever she said actually
you you want to have use may start with
the latrine in fact this particular
stench soup they she traveled around the
world with in her carry-on bag little
bottles labeled
it US government standard bathroom
malodor
smelly feet burnt hair so she had the
energy she traveled around and had
people smell them and rape them were
they pleasant unpleasant did you find
this odor frightening did you find it
edible did you find it wearable and
around it was very hard to find a smell
that all around the world somebody would
say it you know find it universally
horrible something like 3% of Caucasians
fine
Devadas the smell of vomit wearable ok
so so that one the one the one that one
out that was feared and hated all over
the world was US government standard
bathroom a loader and this is a compound
developed in World War two for testing
latrine deodorizers anywhere they had to
have a standardized compound that really
smelled rank and smelled like you know
large open-air hot day 300 menus
he said that smell so that was the
starting point but only the starting
point because if to have an effective
mal odorant you want something that's
not at all familiar because if something
is if you can't place it if you don't
know what the smell is it might be
dangerous so now it's not only repulsive
but it's scary all the more reason for
you to clear the room so so that's so so
in the other now here's the diabolical
part if you're designing a malodor n't
it has a top note which is the first
thing that you get when you take a
little sniff because when you approach a
new smell you tend to be tentative if
you're like I don't know it's going to
be and you take a little whiff so the
top note is sort of fruity and lovely
and that encourages you on the keeper
inhale just so if you're writing like a
wine description for one of these mellow
terrific how would you describe it yet
fruity and floral top note with them
with a robust latrines and yeah so
Senate and they resulting from the
rolling product was called stench soup
southern stench - yeah you know you said
when you run on fresh air which very
grow
you you said that you you're not easily
disgusted and that's clear but were
there any moments say during the writing
of this book when you wished even for a
moment that you were writing about the
wine country
you know Napa or something um no no no
no really not no no I think probably the
closest would be Pam Dalton the monel
lady sent a bunch of these vials to me
well named vials yeah they were vial and
and those those were gag-worthy I'm not
a gag er in general I don't takes a lot
to make me open them I don't on the deck
I'm exactly not we were not opening them
indoors so that sounds like fun what um
I hope I hope I add wasn't grilling at
the time yeah what was the most fun you
had worked on this book what was the
most fun thing that you you did well I
was just like Oh ever since I saw have
you ever seen the film das boat that
film I love that film and I was been
fascinated by submarines and the
opportunity to go on board one out at
sea was was it took a long time to set
it up but it was just really interesting
just fascinating saying that I'd say
that was the most fun for me being on
the Trident submarine and how long were
you on the subway about four four days
and did you have the run of the place I
mean we just sort of doggin around
everywhere and no there are parts of the
there are parts of the submarine that
are off-limits they are secret they're
class there's classified information if
you go into the I was in the enlisted
crew lounge at one point and there on a
table in the corner there's a printer
just a computer printer and it was
labeled secret printer secret printer I
kept hanging out in the crew lounge
hoping something would come in on the
secret projector this is like statute no
so I know I couldn't go in the room
there's a trend service
powered by a nuclear reactor because the
idea is to stay down a long time the
idea is not to be seen or heard at all
because this is a it's you know the
Strategic Defense it's a third of the
nuclear arsenal basically and it's a
third arm of it so they're just being
untrackable down there under the water
for a long time you don't have to cuz
they're not to refuel with it having a
nuclear reactor means never having to
say you're sorry
never having to refuel Oh anyways like
yeah they can stay down a long time I
however was only down for five days I
went out with a group of prospective
commanding officers doing a practical
exam so it's perfect I could go out when
they went out and come back when they
were coming back so that worked out well
where did you sleep - Jeff your own room
was it like a deluxe accommodation would
yeah there are no deluxe accommodations
the closest thing to a deluxe
accommodation on board there are the
people whose beds beds via bunks because
they have bed Pam and some mattress can
it's a bunk amazingly on the floor
and there are some of them set up in
between the nuclear missile silos
they're 20-something nuclear missile
silos the mythic compartment is kind of
like the stacks in a university library
it's four levels because of the very
high silos for four levels and very very
quiet there's not much going on you know
other than Armageddon there's not
there's either Armageddon or nothing
very quiet so the people who sleep there
get a good night's sleep otherwise
you're packed like four or five - a rack
they call it a rack so their bunks and
they're very there and there are some
submarines where you depending on how
big you were you would have to get out
if you wanted to roll over while you're
sleeping up to get out and get back in
they were that cool oh yeah it's sort of
going out of the way yeah so you got to
see a lot of you got to see a lot of
different phases of how the military
operates from their uniforms to the
submarines - to the work they're doing
in surgery with your general injuries if
you were the roach in chief of the armed
forces
and could suggest uh one change from
what you've seen in the military how
something was done what would you what
would you tell the president what the
commander-in-chief what would you what
would you say that you saw that you'd
really like to see changed her I guess
the the the loveliest idea that I came
across in the whole book something that
was suggested in a brainstorming session
right laboratories right at
wright-patterson Air Force Base in the
90s it was a brainstorming session for
non-lethal weapons and there was a guy
there Malcolm Kelly who had an idea that
if you had a compound that created
feelings of brotherly love okay what I
thought I thought he meant is something
that you could spray over the the whole
front and everyone would sort of
suddenly go why are we here we are all
people we are all I love you you know
and I that's how I interpreted it but
then I contacted Malcolm Kelly and I
said is that what you meant he said no I
meant it would be something where if
you're in your foxhole you'd be worried
about somebody coming and making
untoward advances like Isis was
basically weaponized homophobia you're
talking about homophobia I love it but
the first in my head the first version I
thought that would be a lovely and I
interviewed somebody who does somebody
in Israel to studies oxytocin which can
you know it's one of those suppose that
you can buy oxytocin sprays it's
supposedly spray in the meeting and
they'll buy your by your ideas because
it creates fondness yeah exactly and he
actually he said you know because he's
in his related we but we all tried it
once we kind of dosed ourselves and we
all went out to dinner the whole
research staff and he said we were kind
of looking in each other's eyes well on
what point we'd out of some wine - he
said at one point we said well let's
just go spray this over the West Bank in
the Gaza Strip do you think anybody
notices that we're pumping it in right
now oh yeah it's great for book sales so
if you could have at if you can add one
more chapter to the book what would it
have been well I had planned
I wanted to embed actually I plan to
and bed and applied and been accepted by
the US but and I was going to embed with
the chaplains Corps the chaplains go out
with with units say doing you know route
clearance going out in a mind clearing
vehicle looking for IEDs and then and
because they're right in there with the
unit exposed to the same risks I thought
it was it have to have a way an ability
to empathize in a way that other
therapists were support staff and I
thought that was an interesting approach
and I really wanted to do that you have
the chaplain and which I like I like
there's the chaplain who doesn't carry a
weapon and the chaplains assistant his
job is to cover the chaplain and I'm
like well who covers Perry so I was
going to go out with them but I staff
the umbrella of the coalition group this
is not just the United States this was
Afghanistan we're talking about said
right now there because it's during the
drawdown they were only supporting daily
journalists not people doing long-term
long-term projects so but I would have
liked to embed and initially I had an
idea that I wanted to embed with the
fifth Marine Corps dental battalion just
because I don't know the fact that
there's a dental Battalion fascinated me
the Marine Corps don't tell you but they
weren't deploying anytime soon they do
they're doing some humanitarian work
anyway I would have but I wanted to
cover medevac and care in the air I mean
to be it to be doing emergency trauma
care in a vibrating helicopter where
people are firing RPGs and I mean that's
an intense scenario and were challenging
if it would have been really fascinating
so logistically challenging and you know
why for deaf children
but that is anyway so that I would like
to include them so I'm going to ask you
one more question before you get to the
Q&A part of the evening we'll spend
about 15 or 20 minutes on Khan Q&A you
know when you see these these films of
soldiers out in the field you rarely see
any of them carrying rolls of toilet
paper so how do soldiers wipe their
butts good thing I'm glad that you asked
that question because actually what they
do they use
this is one cert this is a one serving
toilet paper from a packet from combat
rations MREs this is once or serving and
I have had these I had stickers made
that say grunt which I thought was a
lovely kind of double entendre and so
anyone who brought anybody who buys a
book will get some grunt toilet paper
and we thought I thought you know I
would actually sort of just you know
just because I have about 2,000 of these
and I can't get rid of them all
okay we have to bring them to New
Orleans yeah I just exactly I should
bring them to new or so so here's how
we'll do the QA and I'll be if you buy a
book you know you can certainly take as
many as you I'll have them at the table
before we get into the Q&A I just want
to make a statement from my own reading
of the book which is to be directed at
Mary which is that um I had a jot this
down so I'd remember to say correctly
but a lot of people talk about what you
do and the gift you have for being funny
in these different situations but very
few people talk about how hard it is
actually be such a great writer
and I just want to say a word about the
writing in grunt it's really it's really
beautiful it's your best written book
and I just want to add also that the the
final paragraph of the book in what in
my opinion is the most unlikely anti-war
book ever written literally moving to
tears so I want to thank you for thanks
thanks Jeff so we'll take questions I
will pick who tells the question Mary
will answer it or we can do it the other
way around anyway we should switch it up
I've been doing this enough sir and
please stand up and wait for the boom
microphone to come above you
are we ready what's your next book
excellent question I wish I knew I don't
know I don't know what the next one is
but I'm always open to suggestions so
view if you get your book sign and you
have something you think would be very
Rocha Bowl let me know because I'm open
to ideas we have to get girls I have to
get grout oh okay
you'll you'll be next okay Carlton we
got to get the boot wait hang on we got
to get the boom mic Carlton what was the
oddest thing you found that you wrote
about in your book the oddest thing oh
gosh what would be the oddest thing I
found I've got one okay
I learned that maggots breathe through
their butt that's pretty weird among
their many many lovely features the
maggot reasons because they go head down
and immerse themselves in what they're
eating kind of like some people at
buffet tables go ahead to completely
immerse their head and they breathe
through their butt thank you for asking
that Carlton yes wait for the boom to
come on down and then we'll funny is
that my question as I read several of
your books and they take a lot of
research and which some of it takes time
to do this research it's not like you
can just you know do it one day and hey
men but I am how do you write your book
simultaneously or do you don't want it
at all one at a time what is I'm yeah
one at a time because really each book
is fifteen little books because I know I
I start a new topic for every chapter
and I'm always starting from zero
because I don't know anything about it
so I'm yeah I'm kind of I've got sort of
15 chapters going at once so I could go
to do two at once I lovely if I could
but no I'm one at a time one burner at a
time is on my life any questions from
back in the room I see up hand in a
sweatshirt or something what's
Mary I want to say thank you that book
is fantastic I've been listening to an
audible yeah and I find myself listening
to it during meal times and before
leaving to some very strange dreams I am
wondering if there was something that
was so disgusting you couldn't even put
it in the book there's something was so
disgusting that I couldn't put it in the
book uh not something that was too
disgusting no there were a cute if you
play there always with my books a few
places where my editor just crosses it
out and goes No
and sometimes it's it's too gross other
times I'm trying to be funny in a place
that's not appropriate so she did some
of that there was nothing that was
actually there were a couple of
descriptions niala in that when I was at
in the operating room and with the these
surgeons who were showing the images
there were a couple of things that she
felt were just a little too graphic so
so yeah there were a couple yeah but
never anything that I had the good sense
to take out yeah the sections about the
euro general general surgery were pretty
disturbing well it's good that it's good
that I left those other parts often
thank you
aye sir
Mary would you say that your greatest
shortcoming as a an esteemed and highly
successful science writer is that you
work too hard or are you just a little
too smart that's the best question ever
let's see work too hard too smart oh
well yeah definitely work too hard
yeah we I work yeah work too hard
get a life Mary hmm how we doing there
for questions yeah yeah one more here I
guess it ask God what is your what is
your educational or experiential
background that led you to have such a
skill in science writing I have a BA in
Psychology yeah no that's what I have so
I my skill is in making an utter pest of
myself with the people that I'm
interviewing and making them treating
them like tutors unpaid tutors for hours
at a time that's that's my that's my
skill and expertise I don't have a
background in hard science I used to say
I have a background in science and
sometimes psychologists would go hey
wait a minute
psychology isn't science you did some
interesting jobs though before you
became a writer I loved that you worked
as it were you're in communications
department where the zoo yeah the new
young San Francisco Zoological Society
mm-hmm what's your favorite animal
oh oh oh monkeys
tombs yeah I'm a sucker for a chimp we
have one last question before we get on
to the signing part of the evening oh
yes you with the green sweater you do
the green sweater on your feet when
we're speaking of diarrhea
all the best questions came that way I
I've used cipro yes that drug so the
military is not aware or doesn't know
write them a letter
yeah right yeah cipro this is faster
than cipro cipro is a pretty hardcore
cipro yeah they are aware of cipro in
fact that's I think what a lot of people
carry cipro
but this would be even better and faster
better faster stronger the six million
dollar drug yeah well all right no more
questions I think we'll get onto the
song probably evening I just want to
thank you all for coming and ladies
gentlemen Mary Roach very long very well
thank you Mary thank you Jeff give us a
second here to redo the stage and then
come on up and if you want to purchase
books there at the registers behind you
thanks everybody
take some toilet paper